here so it's crazy we got a police
escort 25 miles outside Yerevan there's
nobody around we're on a deserted Road
and police escort still has a siren
flash
just worn the occasional goat that we're
on our way
we were just driving up on our way to
shoot a segment and it's strange because
I didn't think we would see Mount Ararat
today I wasn't aware we would see it and
I had heard that it's been difficult to
see and and suddenly we just came around
a corner and there it was
that's apparently where Noah's Ark
landed the Turkish border is right must
be right there and and about Ararat is
just on the other side of the Turkish
border used to be part of Armenia now
it's not
[Music]
we are at the garni temple it's about an
hour's drive outside Yerevan and it is
absolutely stunning we're very fortunate
we're here with Sophie who is the most
famous dance instructor in all of
Armenia this is always old Popeye
cartoons in the 30s I am now wearing the
traditional costume no laughing in
comedy you said to me it's very
important that I show that I am a real
man in this dance and then I make
movements like this how do you do like
this that's my problem
all my life I've been going like this to
show him the man
[Applause]
it's called the old razzmatazz okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
that is my gift to Armenia
[Applause]
you